this is a Fox News Alert the United
States has started carrying out a wave
of retaliatory strikes in Iraq and Syria
it comes 5 days after a deadly drone
attack launched by Iran back Terror
groups that killed three American
soldiers today was the dignified
transfer of their remains let's go right
to National Security correspondent
Jennifer Griffin she's got a live update
from the Pentagon hi Jennifer hi Dana
well at 400m Eastern the usbn carrying
out air strikes on six to seven
locations I'm told in both Iraq and
Syria uh us Central Command just put out
a statement in which they said that 85
targets had been struck at those
different locations that were used by
the Iranian revolutionary guard Corps
125 Munitions were dropped we've
reported and we've heard from us defense
officials that two b1b Lancer bombers
flew from the United States uh to the
region and carried out uh some of these
strikes uh targeting I'm told multiple
multiple targets inside uh these six to
seven locations used by the Iranian
proxies some of the locations were
weapon storage facilities and included
underground bunkers headquarters command
and control nodes for that have been
used for the Iranian backed proxies to
to uh store their drones and and
ballistic missiles and fire on those us
bases as we've reported 166 attack on us
bases since mid- October the one that
turned deadly on Sunday killing three
Americans uh is was the trigger for this
response we're told that this is a
campaign that has been drawn up by us
Central Command that it will last for
days um and that this is the first round
the first round of strikes um we
reported in the at about 3:30 today that
there were explosions inside Syria at
some of these sites we're told they
weren't air strikes at the time but the
that they were explosions it was part of
the uh the preparations being made for
uh the strikes on these targets so a
little bit of confusion earlier today
but we know for certain that the first
air strikes began at 4M Eastern okay
we're going to take it around the table
here will you want to go I'm curious I
know Jennifer asked this earlier today
in speaking to the Pentagon but how much
heads up Iran had that these strikes
were headed their way um how much they
were able to evacuate from the targets
and then what if that is the fact is
what is left from at least a Personnel
standpoint as who was actually the
Target in these strikes well will I
think um it's been the worst kept secret
in Washington that this campaign was
going to begin in the coming days um you
heard the president talk about it you've
heard uh Pentagon officials talk about
it yesterday here at the Pentagon I
asked um secretary Austin that very
question here was the
question has there been too much
telegraphing or is the point not to kill
any Iranian Commanders
in terms of uh telegraphing about
strikes and whether or not um people
leave or would have left you know I
won't speculate uh on on any of that I
would just tell you that uh you know we
will have a a multi-tiered
response so will I think it would be
safe to assume that given the time of
day when they struck after midnight
local time and the telegraphing that had
taken place we had seen reports that Ian
revolutionary guard Court commanders had
been called back to Iran I would be very
surprised if any of them had been at
these bases um there may have been a few
people left behind but but not the
senior commanders um and I think perhaps
that was by Design again you've heard
the Pentagon and others say that they're
not seeking a war with Iran That's Why
Us officials are ruling out any strikes
inside Iran at this time but again this
is the first Salvo they're hoping that
ton gets the message without this having
to escalate great judge pero uh you know
Jennifer I understand that the United
States is saying they're not seeking a
war but at the same time there are those
who believe that if you just hit the
proxies in Syria and Iraq that it's not
going to matter to Iran and that when
Iran can separate uh uh itself from the
proxy saying you know they go Rogue uh
when the truth is the Iran revolutionary
guard Corp both trains them and pays
them uh you know it's kind of
disingenuous and then it what is the
point of our hitting the proxies well
it's a very good question and certainly
this this shell game that Iran has been
playing in the Middle East by arming and
supporting and training these proxies
whether it's in Lebanon with Hezbollah
whether it's these various groups in
Syria and Iraq whether it's the houis in
Yemen whether it's Hamas in the Gaza
Strip there is a Common Thread here and
it is Iran and it is tyan and the US has
not figured out a way to put enough
pressure on Iran to make it painful
enough to for them to stop supporting
these groups and in fact there are some
who believe and this is why it's a very
delicate balancing act for the White
House National Security team as well as
the Pentagon is how not to get baited
into a war with Iran because some
believe that's what Iran wants that they
wanted uh Israel to find itself in a war
with Hamas and for uh the US to uh to
you know stumble into a larger conflict
and so that's what people are trying to
avoid but they also believe that by
striking 85 targets as well as uh you
know a days long if not weeks long
campaign that they can ratchet up the
pressure on Iran they're going to lose a
lot of uh valuable property in with that
their proxies have been using to torment
and taunt uh us bases for the last three
months uh the question you one should
ask is uh what took so long of course
it's it's tragic that three Americans
were killed but but uh there the the US
troops sitting in Iraq and Syria have
been sitting ducks for months now indeed
uh Jennifer Griffin thank you so much we
want to get to Mike Tobin he's in Israel
in Tel Aviv he's got the latest with
reaction there as they I'm sure that
they are on heightened alert as
well well they're always on heightened
alert at this stage D and what I can
really confirm for you right now are
just some of the locations uh we have a
source inside of Iraq who says indeed
there have been multiple targets struck
in the area of Alim which is the Western
border of Iraq very near Syria and this
following reports throughout the day
that the almadine the deer azur area the
Abu Kamal area were all hit uh and this
these are areas that are kind of near
the uh some of those cities are just on
the banks of the Euphrates River Alim is
immediately across the border so a lot
of the real estate at least where a lot
of the strikes have been concentrated is
not a whole lot of real estate
concentrated into about a 60 mile area
uh we know that there are other strikes
inside of Iraq the US confirming today
that there were some 85 different
targets hit uh by some 125 different
Munitions and that is dramatically
different from the early reports we
heard that some eight different targets
were hit uh we anticipated that the
numbers would change and indeed they did
change as the US is now confirming that
they used two of those big b1b bombers
uh to hit some of those targets inside
of Iraq Dana Mike we're going to take it
on the table Richard has a question but
let me just quickly ask you there was
talk earlier this week that there was um
communication about a possible ceasefire
in order to get more hostages out do you
know where that stands at this
moment it stands at the point where
Hamas and um Islamic Jihad officials met
and they set out a number of their
demands they said you're going to need
to see a massive prisoner release they
want to see all is Israelis withdraw
from the Gaza Strip and a cessation of
of of uh of uh combat inside of the Gaza
Strip they also want to see some
restoration rebuilding for all the
destruction that was done inside of the
Gaza Strip so so you have very broad uh
demands if you will coming from the
leadership of uh Palestinian Islamic
Jihad and Hamas as far as a prisoner
release goes and that puts them very far
apart from Benjamin Netanyahu who says
they want to see all of the prisoners
released and Hamas dismantled all right
Richard um thanks for joining us Mike
now picking up where Dana left off how
does the how does the ceasefire
negotiations sort of interplay with this
strike and the fact that we now know
today that um secretary blinkin will be
returning to the region to visit Israel
the West Bank uh Qatar and Saudi
Arabia well clearly secretary blinkin is
hitting all of the key players involved
in this uh particularly when he talks to
the qataris because the qataris are the
primary Avenue to get in and talk to
Hamas he can't discuss with Hamas
directly so the fact that secretary
blinkin is coming here is showing that
at least there's an effort to move
forward uh with these hostage release
negotiations but keep in mind you have
to be patient and unfortunately you have
to be pessimistic if if you look at the
example of gillad Shalit when he was
kidnapped it took 6 years and a thousand
Palestinian prisoners to get him
released so now you're talking about
over a hundred uh that we know that are
still alive or at least we have
information that are still alive in
Hamas captivity uh so you can't be
optimistic that you're really talking
about more than women and children and
elderly uh being released released in
this round of talks all right Mike Tobin
thank you want to get to Rich Edson he's
at the White House with the latest there
hi Rich he Dana we've just gotten a
statement from president in the first
we've heard from him since these
retaliatory strikes he notes that he did
attend the dignified transfer of the
three soldiers who were killed in that
drone strike over the weekend and now
the response to this he says this
afternoon at his Direction US military
forces struck targets at facilities in
Iraq and Syria that the irgc that's the
Iran revolutionary guard Corps and
Affiliated militia used to attack US
forces he goes on to say that our
response began today and it will
continue at a time and place of our
choosing that's a line at the White
House and the administration have been
using now for some time he also says the
US does not seek conflict in the Middle
East or anywhere else in the world but
let all those who might seek to do us
harm know this if you harm an American
we will respond president as he
mentioned attended that dignified
transfer earlier today he's back home at
his home in Delaware uh today where uh
we expect uh we weren't expected to hear
much more from him today until he
released the statement um there has been
plenty of criticism of the White House
and the time that it has taken in this
response several days uh since the Drone
attack on early Sunday you had a number
of congressional Republicans saying that
it should have been a robust response
and one that should have happened
shortly therea that attack um Senator
Lindsey Graham had said earlier today
before the details of the strike came
out that the lapse of time has lessened
the impact of deterrence and by not
hitting oil infrastructure in Iran or
revolutionary guard Personnel you will
have failed to make the point Iran is
one of those subjects one of the many
subjects that Republicans and the White
House have been at odds over since the
beginning of the administration the
White House has tried to get the us back
into the Iran nuclear deal those
attempts have failed there was the
prisoner swap and you remember the $6
billion that the administration uh was
going to unfreeze for Iranian assets the
US said that that fell apart especially
after uh the Hamas attack on Israel and
Iran's support for H so this continues
to be a point of friction and we'll get
more updates from Capitol Hill as the
details come out quick question from me
and then the judge and will I I just
have has the White House called a lid
for the day the White House called a lid
a couple of hours ago which is why this
statement was a surprise lid of course
meaning you're not going to hear from
the president today and then of course
we did and so as this continues we may
expect to hear more from Administration
officials and from the White House all
right judine you know it's very
interesting to hear the administration
say quote if you harm an American we
will respond it it it appears that they
harmed over a 100 Americans before the
United States responded and the United
States is making it clear that it
doesn't want a broader War I mean the
the the Republicans obviously don't
agree with the stance of this
Administration I mean does anyone think
this is really going to change things
based upon this kind of tepid response
yeah you know judge you look at the
nearly 170 attacks on us positions in
Iraq and in Syria and now in Jordan
since the middle of October and there
has been plenty of criticism about the
several attacks that the US has had on
positions in Iraq and Syria since those
attacks began and sort of the timeline
that it took just for those retaliatory
responses and now what's uh ostensibly
the largest response that we've had to
date the Administration has Justified
its responses in saying that it's trying
to maintain deterrence by trying to
ensure that this doesn't spread wider a
conflict doesn't spread wider in the
Middle East because you've got Israel
fighting Hamas and Gaza you've got
Israel and Hezbollah on the Lebanon
border going back and forth you've got
the houthis in Yemen attacking shipping
in the Gulf of Aiden and in the Red Sea
and now you've got all of these attacks
on American positions on the Middle East
but the Republicans have argued and
those like Senator Lindsey Graham have
argued that unless you have something
that is really robust and shows that you
mean business you're not showing that in
fact you're only inviting more of these
attacks Jetson at the White House thank
you and if they pop the lid again let us
know let you know okay take a on the
table here judge you know what's
interesting about all of this is that
the United States is in my last question
to rich is the United States is not
going to respond it's not by going into
tyan okay when Donald Trump was
President he took took out salaman who
was the head of the Iran revolutionary
guard Corp now if the United States made
a decision to go after that Island
wherever that island is where they have
that oil supply then we would hurt Iran
economically and hurt consequently all
of the proxies the problem is if we did
that then the price of oil would go up
in a presidential year so you know the
administration again is in this
schizophrenic like we're going to let
Iran sell oil in the open market we're
going to let him Pat the billions of
dollars that they got from our hostage
exchange but we're going to warn them
not to touch Americans but only after
they touch a hundred and then kill three
will we respond it's a schizophrenic
it's not clear what we're willing to do
there's a huge amount of cap I mean if
if the if they've already done 85
strikes 85 targets that's a huge amount
of cap capacity that Iranian back who um
proxies have in order to attack our
troops who are there so you know if
there's if there's several more days of
this then that's a lot of capability
that we've allowed them to build up I I
would make two points and I would be
curious uh actually Greg it's your
response to this but one in the micro
and one in the macro on the micro I
don't see that much has actually
happened in in terms of of some strikes
yes that has occurred what is it done to
deter Iran if they have a heads up
warning to pull their people out then I
don't know that anything message has
been sent that would deter them in the
future but the macro is and forgive the
not so subtle plug but I had Senator ran
Paul on my digital show this week to
will K show and he said this he said
when it comes to the houthis strike them
and strike them hard they're they're
messing with international shipping
lanes when it comes to this story and
what we're looking at right now why do
we have guys scattered across Syria why
do we have guys scattered across Iraq
why are we leaving El vulnerable to the
potential for an attack to Iran hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else